the rise of socialism has never been
more clear right now in America there
are forces dug in organized and
well-funded doing whatever is necessary
to make socialism happen
today's demonstrations are part of an
ongoing step-by-step agenda to change
our country at its very core
they demand the abolition of ice
immigration and customs enforcement and
the zero tolerance policy of the Trump
administration I think we need to
abolish ice that seems really clear they
have strayed so far from the interests
of the American people and the interests
of humanity Cynthia are you stupid I
know as an actress you're used to saying
what's on the script and this government
thing is new to you but strayed so far
from the interest of the American people
the whole point of Vice is to protect
the American people from illegals who
would do us harm physically and
financially and listen to this one ice
isn't doing what it was created to do
it's being used as his own personal
police force and in those actions it's
actually making us less safe ice isn't
doing what it was created to do ice is
doing exactly what it was created to do
are you stupid too and the president is
using it as his own police force when
ice was doing its job in 2009 to 2016
was it Obama's police force and you
think ice is making us less safe I've
got two words for you
Kate Steinle a primer for all you
geniuses out there ice does not separate
children and parents at the border
border patrol does that and if you
abolish ice who arrests the drug dealers
and the Coyotes coming across our border
in droves delivering 80 percent of the
narcotics and 90 percent of the heroin
here and pray tell who Deportes the
illegal who committed rape when he
finishes his jail time should we just
let bygones be bygones and throw down
the welcome mat to the local YMCA give
him his food stamps and call it a day
you don't want them too important maybe
they ought to come live with you and
Kirsten Gillibrand a United States
Senator who has ambition to run for
president in 2020 says we should protect
families that need our help and that is
not what ice is doing today and that's
why I believe you should get rid of it
start over
reimagine it and build something that
actually works why is it that whenever a
Democrat doesn't want to follow the law
they say it's broken the immigration
system is broken ice is broken how about
I say the tax system is broken and we
don't then have to pay our taxes and we
can go suck another capitalist country
dry that way none of us have to pay
taxes the truth Americans want the
immigration laws enforced even 60% of
the Democrats want that those laws
protect jobs and the more people who
come in especially the poor ones the
more taxes we pay for their education
medication housing and social services
and when we don't know who's coming in
we cannot screen for gangs and drug
dealing operatives
not to mention none of this is fair to
those immigrants who played by the rules
the narrative of today's protest is
backwards those marching object to
adults who cross the border being
separated from their children it
happened even before Trump was president
no one cared objected or protested Trump
issues an executive order to end the
family separations and yet they still
march so what's going on the overarching
message is that illegals people who do
not respect our laws are entitled to
everything that we Americans are that
they're being wronged by Americans if we
don't share our wealth our capitalist
success and our way of life with them
this my friends is socialism like the
women's March these anti-trump protests
are extremely well organized and they
are more than political
they are ideological we are witnessing
the evolution of a socialist coup and if
you don't believe what I'm saying take
it from their mouths
did you hear it if your boarders F your
walls we will make your system fall this
week's primary win by a 28-year old
socialist congressional candidate who
took down a well-funded long term New
York congressman is about more than one
district and although Alexandra Ocasio
Cortez deserves credit for working hard
she won with the assistance of the
Democratic socialists of America and
don't forget a little-known Socialist
from Vermont would have been the
Democratic candidate for president in
2016 but for the Hillary Clinton
corruption of the Democratic National
Committee and make no mistake folks
socialists are beginning to win
elections at the state and national
level
defeating even long-term incumbents and
expect more hard left Democratic
candidates to run you know even Obama's
cradle-to-grave fictional ad called the
life of julia suggests an
anti-capitalist Socialist framework and
for those of you who need reminding
socialism doesn't work the crushing
poverty and violence in Venezuela is
just the latest example according to The
Wall Street Journal people go through
garbage bags full of rubbish to take
whatever they can and then try to sell
the empty bags socialism when private
property in the distribution of income
is subject to state control hasn't
worked out very well in Sweden either
national health care far from what they
promised pregnant mothers are turned
away from maternity wards because of
overcrowding causing women to give birth
on the street socialists have or want
what you have
I for one work hard pay taxes believe in
capitalism and have no plan to move to
Venezuela or Sweden one of my heroes
Margaret Thatcher put it best when she
said the trouble with socialism is that
eventually you run out of other people's
money and that's my open tell me what
you think on my Facebook page Twitter
and Instagram hashtag judge Janine